i think you're going to find this
interesting i've talked to you before
about the important distinction between
a tv lawyer and a courtroom lawyer
for a while now we have been referring
to
rudy giuliani as donald trump's
television lawyer for a long time
he goes on tv and he represents donald
trump but he defends trump in a way
that's different than what you would see
in a courtroom
many of the things that a tv lawyer can
say are different than what an actual
courtroom lawyer would say you can't
make the same claims in front of a judge
that you would potentially be making on
television
these two worlds collided and exploded
in dramatic fashion this week because it
was announced on sunday or monday
that rudy would be representing donald
trump
in court in court in pennsylvania
in one of these completely bogus voter
fraud
cases and rudy giuliani actually
was going to be expected to behave the
way
a courtroom lawyer behaves rather than a
television lawyer and what's just
fascinating
about that is that when rudy giuliani
was directly pressed by the judge
in pennsylvania about whether he is
actually alleging
that voter fraud took place rudy
giuliani said
i am not alleging that this is it's so
important to understand this because
it's not just rudy giuliani this has
happened with a numerous trump lawyers
in court in filing these various briefs
and motions and complaints
when they've been asked are you alleging
actual voter fraud they all say no
um and it's just perfect because rudy
went in
with all sorts of vague claims that
left-leaning counties
conspired to hurt donald trump well
what does that actually mean happen
though he went in with claims that
absentee voting was unfairly
administered
in some counties versus others but when
it came down to it he was asked
are you alleging fraud in court
and rudy said no your honor we are not
and then he went on to say well we
believe the process was fraudulent which
is kind of a distinction without a
difference but it's still relevant
rudy when put in front of a judge rather
than in front of judge jeanine pirro on
fox news who's
just a tv host in front of an actual
judge in a court of law
he can't actually say we are alleging
specific fraud instead he says we
believe the process
was generally fraudulent and led to
i guess what he sees as the wrong
results which is that donald trump lost
this is the final confirmation we needed
that even they know when they allege
fraud took place in public they don't
really believe it or at least
they recognize they don't have the
evidence to claim that that's what took
place
in front of an actual judge in a court
of law now rudy wasn't exactly perfect
during the court appearance
he did stop short of saying we are
alleging fraud because they aren't
actually
but he did at one point suggest that
some kind of democratic mafia
stole the election from joe biden
there's no evidence of that
whatsoever rudy also apparently
committed perjury
rudy giuliani submitted a petition to
the court in which he wrote that he is a
member in good standing
of the washington d.c bar association
when in reality rudy giuliani is
currently suspended from the d.c
bar because get this he didn't pay his
dues
to the washington dc bar isn't that just
perfect
trump doesn't pay his contractors and
lawyers worry
trump's not going to pay them and rudy
didn't pay
to remain part of the dc bar which led
to
him perjuring himself when he told the
pennsylvania court
that he was a member in good standing of
the dc bar now that's an aside
the question is if you are not
alleging fraud why are you here to make
general points about elections
because it sure as hell seems like
you're here to try to overturn the
results of the pennsylvania election
and these lawyers that donald trump has
working for him are not going to be able
to get past
any judge with a reasonable
understanding of what they're doing
and so far that's why everything is
getting thrown out
by court after court after court and by
the way
speaking of judges this is why the
republican party
has been 110 focused pedal to the medal
during donald trump's presidency
on getting as many loyalists into
federal judge positions
as possible they know that on a lot of
issues
the law is not on their side so they
prepare
to corrupt the law by putting in place
their cronies and i hate to admit it
they've succeeded to a great degree i've
talked about this before
mitch mcconnell i think is a despicable
guy if you are a republican
you see mitch mcconnell and you
recognize this is the guy
who has done an amazing job of
installing
hundreds of judges oh i mean if you go
pre-trump it could even be
maybe it's even over a thousand i don't
know uh endless
judges who are going to continue ruling
in a um a partisan way
whether you've got a democrat or a
republican in the white house as we are
very quickly going to see during the
first couple of years of the joe biden
administration they have done a really
good job
i i think they're horrible uh i think
these judges are horrible
but if you are them you have to look at
mitch mcconnell and say this this guy
has been incredibly successful
and while the trump scandals continue to
rage
they keep putting judges in judges they
didn't even stop during coronavirus
and it is something that we will have to
contend with for a long time in the
united states and
listen if they had gotten more of them
in you might have actually seen some of
these court cases about supposed voter
fraud
go in donald trump's favor maybe some
still will for now
they have not make sure you're following
the david pakman show on instagram
at davidpakmanshow you can also follow
me
at david.pakman we will take a quick
break and be back with much more
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want
to sample a book before you buy the
entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video